ladies and gentlemen a fascist
[Applause]
my fellow Americans a war is about to be
waged between everything you love and
everything you hate our very right to
exist as a people is under attack
foreign invaders disguised as immigrants
and refugees are being imported to our
lands by a cabal of globalist elites and
if we don't stop it soon the result will
be raped chaos and the end of
civilization as we know it I want you to
imagine the faces of your wives and
children picture their pure white
innocent faces now watch as those same
wives are violated those same children
dashed to pieces under the black boots
of the third world poured does that
thought fill you with rage good we must
be prepared to fight to fight for our
children and for our nation and for our
history and for our culture to fight for
the homeland we've always known and the
people we've always loved
make America great again Heil Hitler
ladies and gentlemen a leftist
[Applause]
so actually according to Hegel the for
itself can only be actualized through
the M itself so the individuation of the
subject necessarily demands the
transcendence of the dialectical object
through the sublimation of negative
materiality
you you racists death the
capitalized Oh
Cael stay down
[Applause]
[Music]
so that speech didn't go too well huh
well what do you expect we have the
politicians against us a media run by
giant corporations and a complacent
white middle class that prefers order to
justice opposition to leftism
is hardly surprising so let's accept at
all that's true the game is rigged fine
now how do you respond to that situation
do you change nothing about your
strategy at all and then blame the
system when the predictable happens or
do you try to improve your rhetoric
somehow look I don't really need optics
advice from a boutique we're s beat who
put style over substance and thinks that
shining a pink light and everything can
cover up her counter-revolutionary
Trotskyite tendencies I mean are you
even a communist no I'm not a communist
well why not mmm I like stuff like this
and I like this and I like this that's
why I can't be a communist Justine you
do realize that Marxism distinguishes
between private property and personal
property right you're allowed to own
possessions
you just can't exploit people by owning
the means of production well most of my
stuff was made by Chinese slaves well
you should feel bad about that look I'm
just trying to help you out here Queer
Eye for the marxist-leninist
you know actually I'm an
anarcho-syndicalist right do you have
any friends who are leftist militants
that's what I thought you know tabby
people think you're weird and they're
afraid of you
well fascists are afraid of me really
well let's take a look at your Twitter
feed let's see we've got guillotine
soviet memes liberals get the bullet too
no wonder why everyone thinks
you're some kind of staring terrorists
okay Jesus let's hear your mind-blowing
revelations of our respectability
politics great let's start by taking a
look at these patches and pins positives
first the Rose is great love the rose
fantastic now the hammer and sickle
we're gonna need to get rid of that I'm
just wearing it ironically no don't you
start with that it makes me think of red
lines and gulags and it needs to go well
maybe you're right fine I'll get rid of
it see I can think about optic what's
that in your bag oh this yeah we're
gonna need to do something about that
too now hold on getting rid of the
hammer and sickle is one thing but marks
as a foundational thinker in the history
of progressive I'm not talking about
getting rid of marks I'm talking about
giving him a makeover I mean just look
at the cover of that thing it's making
me depressed just looking at it red and
gold what is this foreign like a
Chinese or a Soviet flag it's not
American I don't trust it I don't let
the cut of its jib so you wanna marx
engels read or rap than an American flag
oh I can do you better than that
let's start with a gradient got a grid
maybe a wave grid let's get some shiny
Fox maybe a bust
a pink bust with 3d glasses pink glasses
the palm trees
[Music]
how about this lots of brands more more
MORE
oh my god it's beautiful ok one more one
more
a pink sealed Chiclets yes girl yeah I
actually hate you
hello fellow whites do you have a moment
to talk about the need to secure a
homeland for our people in the future
for white children the hell out of your
voice smash your face you Nazi
effective isn't it well I see your point
but this whole antiva thing I can't help
but wonder from a strict PR perspective
if there's some way you can to do that
are you saying we shouldn't punch Nazis
I'm saying if 30,000 people show up to
counter protest Nazis you won't have to
[Music]
but that means getting 30,000 people on
your side what you're not gonna do by
tweeting death threats and communist
propaganda and using words like
dialectic and telling everyone to read
obscure European philosophers with
unpronounceable names and unintelligible
ideas and smashing windows for no reason
that anyone can understand or sympathize
with and expecting that people are gonna
want to leave their jobs and comfortable
lives to join a violent revolution to
establish an economic system primarily
associated with starvation and
dictatorship well that's an unfair
Association real communism doesn't lead
to starvation and dictatorship has there
ever been real communism
well yes between 1910 and 1912 and
revolutionary Eastern Cameroon a
thriving though short-lived communist
utopia did flourish until it was smashed
by Western imperialism right but what's
the chance of that actually happening on
a large scale in the near future you
seem to not even care about what's
actually possible that's how deep you
are and pure theory and if anything is
anti-marxist it's that you know
sometimes I think you secretly don't
want your ideas to succeed you actually
enjoy being a pariah whose political
ideas never gain any traction because if
you have purely theoretical political
beliefs
you're never accountable for the way
things are going I'm not saying theory
is everything only that there's no
practice without theory look I'm not
some kind of political scientist for all
I know you could be correct I'm just
saying it's a tough sell and you are not
selling it well I wouldn't have to work
so hard to sell it if we didn't live in
a neoliberal intellectual void we're
complacent so called centrists with
corporate backing have shifted the
Overton Window one inch left of fascism
under the heading of free speech and
classical liberalism if someone ready to
bring their wares to the free
marketplace of ideas
hey you leave centrists alone thanks
Justine Jacky get out of here you're
embarrassing me in front of my auntie
for friends I'll see you at brunch
mmm Oh sighs what the hell was that
brunch
you got a brunch with these people well
it's more of a boozy afternoon tea
afternoon tea does jiva's bring around
Madeleine cookies and fresh sliced lemon
wedges no but I do have a very nice
Windsor China tea set unbelievable you
get the bullet too you got the goddamn
bullet too oh come on me wait what do
you want me to do drink victory gin out
of a rusty Harrington like the
anti-imperialist revolutionaries in
Eastern Cameroon I mean nothing is ever
good enough for you people I'm gonna be
munching on a cigar the South American
jungle shooting at capitalists with a
black beret and an eyepatch and I still
wouldn't be left-wing enough for you
well why don't you start by not going to
afternoon tea with people who protect
fascists and not complaining about the
optics of people who are risking their
lives to keep you safe how is anti-fog
keeping me safe you do realize don't you
that 99% of what anti food does is not
punching Nazis most of what we do is
behind the scenes organizing
infiltrating fascist groups daxing them
disrupting their recruitment and yes we
do engage in defensive violence of
fascist rallies and one of these days if
you can bear to tear yourself away from
your teeth set long enough you're gonna
be on a counter protest and the black
bloc is gonna save your life because you
don't look like you can fight and the
police certainly aren't gonna save you
well maybe so I mean I'm the first to
admit these are not Nazi punching hands
so I'm not gonna get in your way but in
a free marketplace of ideas and like it
or not that's what we're pretty mark I
can't help but think that which you are
matters less than what you seem to be
and black-clad thugs and masks smashing
things on the street seems pretty scary
oh come on you have to admit there's
something kind of appealing about a guy
in a mask what about a girl and a mask
[Music]
I think we should just be friends while
I figure myself out well it was worth a
shot
look my point is you can't just win the
war in the street you also have to win
the war in the heart and the mind I mean
the propaganda war Shh
don't call it propaganda there could be
liberals listening look what the left
needs to get and what the centrists need
to get and what only I and the fascists
seem to understand is that reason
doesn't matter very well by here we got
interests hate about social justice
warriors it's not that they don't have
good reasons and support of their
arguments is that they're not cool right
social justice warriors are not cool
what do you mean they're not popular no
no no I mean they're not cool you can be
unpopular and still cool and in fact you
can be cool to be unpopular so what does
it mean to be cool cool is calm detached
and in control of yourself and the
leading complaint about social justice
warriors is that they're emotional the
social justice warriors who everyone
cringes that online are people who I'm
sure are nice people but we're having a
bad moment and they're caught on camera
in the middle of an outburst they're out
of control and that's the problem it's
not cool look this detached ironic
pretend not to give a posturing
that white men mistake for rationality
is really just the self celebration of
comfortable privileged people with
nothing at stake people on the left are
never gonna be cool because anger and
emotion are irrational responses to
injustice I thought you'd say that but
what you're failing to consider is that
it's possible to be both angry and cool
and what do you get when you sprinkle a
little anger into a glass of cool what
you get
[Music]
I'm sorry what
and that's what we on the Left need to
become what the hell are you talking
about
Miles Davis incredibly cool but pretty
angry did not take from way people
but also ice cold so your
plan is to win over centrists by
becoming an ice cold
precisely what we need is social justice
drugs and rock and roll this is
ridiculous
and I suppose you think this is
ridiculous I think it's stalemate no
it's not
my queen is wide-opened no it isn't take
me I'm gonna get going now
wait where are you going I'm gonna go
back to the famish well be careful
sure enjoy your tea tomorrow what
goddamn lunatic I'm gonna miss her
[Music]
whatever happened to Bruce and Trixie
they got into a fight on skype remember
anyway they killed each other they're
both dead they kind of fired guns off in
random directions it's best not to think
about it too much